have you ever been sat in math class and
the teachers explaining quadratic
equations or something full of equations
and you understand everything it's the
worst right
well if that's you this video is here to
help here is how to suck at maths with
five easy tips tip 1 if you don't
understand something do not ask for help
put yourself back in the classroom put
yourself in the position we've all been
in you've just been taught something new
some new concept and the teachers given
the class a bunch of questions to test
how what you understand it you don't
understand this new concept at all
you're looking down the problems and
you're clueless the pro move here is to
look around and see what other people
are doing some people are getting on
with the questions they understand some
people are looking just as confused as
you now what do you do you stay silent
there is a professional teacher in this
room someone who has studied maths for
10 years someone who has a degree in the
subject who is in this job to help you
understand the subject matter better if
you ask them a question there was a very
real risk that you will come away with a
better understanding of maths if you ask
a teacher for help you are like 99%
guaranteed to improve your ability
don't take that chance tip 2 if you find
something difficult give up next a
really easy one this is super simple to
implement whenever you're given a
question look at it decide whether or
not you think you can do it and if you
think it's too difficult give up this
one's really important guys one of the
most common mistakes people make in
trying to suck at maths is pushing
through difficulties rather than giving
up like someone might be given a problem
that they thinks too difficult so they
might make it simpler and simpler and
simpler until they find the version of
the problem that they can answer and if
they were to give up their I give them
partial marks but the thing you
absolutely have to avoid doing the big
mistake is to then increase the
complexity of the problem like adding
bits to it and improving your
understanding until you can eventually
get back to the original version of the
problem and actually answer it I can't
stress this enough guys if you want to
suck at maths you've got to accept the
level you're at now and never want to
improve stay in your lane here's a 5
second rule of
which might help if you can't answer a
question in five seconds then move on
you can't do it
five seconds should be enough time to
determine whether or not you could ever
answer a particular question or not tip
3 if you find something in maths
interesting
stay away here I'm gonna use a quote
from Marcus DeSoto writing in The
Guardian one of the books my teacher
recommended was gh Hardy's and
mathematicians apology at the time I was
very interested in music I was learning
the trumpet hanging out with the RT
crowd doing plays and singing in choirs
but I also had a desire for things that
made logical sense for solving puzzles
for a rational perspective on the world
a mathematicians apology suddenly opened
up a bridge between these two competing
desires these two cultures it's rookie
error there is nothing more dangerous to
a lack of understanding than interest in
the subject so as soon as you find even
the tiniest bit of maths interesting
under no circumstances pursue that thing
discipline guys don't google it
definitely don't ask your teacher
questions about it and don't try and
find out anything more about it in any
way you have been taught everything in
your lessons for a reason don't add any
extra knowledge to that because you
might come away with a better
understanding of what you're taught in
class tip 4 only do the questions you're
set as homework I've got two words for
you guys bare minimum homework is
literally only set to improve your
understanding in class a lot of people
will tell you that homeworks actually
set to give teachers something to do
they don't have very much to do but I'm
telling you
homework is carefully designed to make
you better at maths so you can't not do
it you'll get in trouble for
disrespecting the system or something so
you have to do the homework but you
don't have to try while doing the
homework so spend the minimum time on it
possible bare minimum well you have to
do the homework absolutely avoid up all
costs doing any extra problems whether
that's in textbooks or in websites
or in popular science books if you do
extra problems off of your own
motivation you will get better at maths
so don't do it
tip five remember maths isn't for you
you're not good at maths you'll never be
good at maths it's just not the way your
brain works we all know that you have to
have a brain that works in a particular
way to be good at maths and if you're
good at maths you can't be good at
anything else the same way that someone
who speaks French can only speak French
this is probably the most difficult tip
to put into action because it's about a
mindset rather than a specific thing you
should be doing personally I find it
easiest to implement using a mental
mantra every time someone mentions maths
or math class I make sure to say to
myself maths
I'm not good at maths I'll never be good
at maths in fact you can say this out
loud to your friends if you have a
friend that is good at maths make sure
you say that every time they bring up
the subject the important thing is to
cultivate a negative mental state if you
preclude the possibility that you'll
ever be good at maths you're
guaranteeing that you will never be good
at maths so those are my five tips but
before summarizing it and wrapping up
actually I'm gonna add a bonus tip here
if you're serious about sucking at maths
there's a website you need to avoid at
all costs in fact blacklist it if at all
possible I'm gonna show you where it is
so you know where to avoid it I'm gonna
have to accidentally learn something
it's okay it's name it's it's brilliant
dog it's brilliant dog something you
absolutely have to avoid if you want to
suck at maths is doing problems outside
of your homework and especially websites
which have problems which explain the
answer if you get something wrong like
that will only help improve your
understanding I just can't oh it's like
kryptonite for sucking at maths
if you insist on checking out Brillon
and if you don't understand something
never ever look at the solution which
will cause you to stretch your abilities
and make you better at maths in fact
since the core
are so well constructed you should you
should just give up brilliant
immediately there's there's no point in
continuing I'm gonna leave a link to
this in the description so you know
exactly what to blacklist
okay remember if you want to suck at
Matt's here are five tips to help if you
don't understand something do not ask
for help if you find something difficult
give up if you find something a maths
interesting
stay away only do the questions you're
set as homework and remember
maths isn't for you this is a serious
issue and I hope this blog has been
instructive and helping you suck at
maths if you'd like some case studies of
sheer mathematical incompetence then I
highly recommend you check out my vlogs
from my PhD just remember maths is lame
no one will like you if you're good at
it and if you become good at it there's
a very real risk they'll end up with an
interesting high paying job wait
[Music]
you